all right and we're back with another
movie review we're gonna do Mad Max -
alright also known as Mad Max road
warrior yeah
yeah this is one of the definitive
action movies probably of all times
oh yeah just because of how dangerous it
was to make yeah they don't make them
like this anymore except for fury road
but we'll get into that because they
made this movie Miller made this movie
and then he's like it stood the test of
time for like decades you know like this
is the most badass heavy metal style
action movie of all times but you know
what
[ __ ] that here's another one it's even
bigger yeah that's what happened with
fury road that yeah seriously and like I
don't even know if we want to do like a
separate review of that because like
[ __ ] I have to tell you right now I
[ __ ] love fury road because it's I
will almost I don't want to say it's a
perfect movie but almost nothing is but
I almost want to say that road warrior
is a perfect movie yeah it's damn near
perfect yeah I mean I've tried to find
problems with the movie over the decades
I just can't the coolest thing about
George Miller and like I like the first
Mad Max movie but it's kind of a
different kind of movie then it's funny
because the first Mad Max movie which
was like a huge success in Australia
obviously and in a lot of other
countries too it was kind of a cult
movie in the US yeah involved in the USS
yes because of the studio's they dubbed
it yes from Australia cuz they said well
people won't understand it's like some
genius and the studious it's like Mad
Max and maybe the first Mad Max you can
make the argument but like you don't
really have to know what they're saying
I mean one yeah you can understand it
because we got the first Mad Max we have
it on Blu right now and they restored
the original soundtrack the original
actors talking which thank Christ they
did that yeah because it's a lot better
it's a lot better they original and I
see no trouble understanding what their
that was just some American dudes in the
studios
pinky and I I think of during the time
for movies were equated with cheap so
right yes they went if the studio bought
a foreign movie they tried the dove
American dialogue like to the matter try
to make it an American movie bad idea
because Mad Max is the perfect
Australian movie yeah it's in the bodies
Australia yeah it's all Outback e yes it
has to be that that's that's part of its
thing that's worth universe that's part
of its charm it doesn't work when it's
Americans yes it's not the same not
saying yes so the first Mad Max was
which kind of like I don't know if it
was pre-apocalyptic but it was kind of
like it was at the it was at the end of
civilization and I don't think now did
they ever say like in the Mad Max
universe was there like a nuclear war or
was it just like it was a mixture of
everything yeah there was fallout
remember it that's true I think was
mostly addressed in the odd Thunderdome
he pulls that Geiger counter yeah that's
right yeah so yeah there wasn't a
nuclear war but there was other things
too there was a societal breakdown that
it happened even before the nuclear war
yeah it's invert and then by the time
that by the time that fury road comes
around the entire Hall the water is gone
yeah to the atmosphere and every way
that's like and a lot of people have
radiation sickness and mutations you
have to say yeah half lights and stuff
so this is before that this is Mad Max 2
also known as road warrior and it's
funny they made up the title road
warrior for the American audience
because most Americans hadn't seen
Batman 1 so but the dumb thing is that I
mean there were two years in between the
two movies in the timeline of the film I
think it's supposed to be five years but
what I learned close enough so yeah so
two years later they made it but what
happened was even though the first Mad
Max was not like a success in America I
guess it was cheap to show on cable TV
so by the time that road warrior came
out people knew that
like it was still kind of a cult movie
but people still know but I think that
when they released Mad Max 2 which it's
called Mad Max 2 everywhere else in the
world right they thought well let's just
give it like a kind of a generic title
doesn't have anything to do with that
because you know most Americans might
not know who that character is they're
like what Mad Max - it was [ __ ] me but
it was kind of a cult thing up until
then but you know exactly the road war
yeah now they call it Mad Max 2 : the
road warriors kind of what they what
they do max one was a good movie I'm a
motorcycle guy and I actually get more
out of it I think than a lot of non
motorcycle guys because I've heard their
reviews of Mad Max 1 yeah it's kind of
boring but if you're a motorcycle guy
it's not quite as bored because you're
seeing some really cool motorcycles for
the early eighties motorcycles yeah you
know and they're kind of dressed up and
in unique ways you know like a Kawasaki
z1000 dressed up as a police bike ran
back with kind of a futuristic for the
time writing leathers and you know
unusual helmets you know an unusual
fairings on mostly Kawasaki a matter of
fact I think they were all Kawasaki's
yeah I think Kawasaki gave him a bunch
of motorcycles to make the movie with
anyway that was that was George Miller's
very first film Mad Max Wandy and it did
it is boring it was in certain ways
where that probably was supposed to be
maybe about a half hour movie that they
stretched out to be about 90 minutes
yeah I think maybe I'm not kinda like
him but for but there were a lot of
movies in the 70s that were like that
late seventies unusual for the time yeah
what year was Mad Max one I think was it
1980 it was a 1979 well road warrior
came out in 81 yes I guess it was 79 79
it may have been when it was released in
the US it might have been released
Google but later maybe it was that late
about a year later the crazy thing
though is that the difference in quality
between the first Mad Max movie and the
road warrior is like a huge and I mean
for a director only
years later yeah I'm like I said the
first Mad Max is a good movie but then
the road warrior comes out and it's like
[ __ ] yeah yeah like it got it was so
much better it was just so much
everything like it's almost like he had
just kind of like come out of this
chrysalis
well Miller Miller was not a director he
was a young guy who was a doctor yeah
and he had no experience as a director
right and you know so he was just
working with money he was able to come
up with him heinous press yeah
Mad Max one was a huge success in
Australia you know getting the funds
together to make Road Warrior was a lot
easier he had a much bigger budget and
by then I think he'd really honed his
craft oh yeah because as a that this
movie's action-packed and it's nonstop
oh yeah and on a on a mythical
storytelling level road warrior is damn
near perfect it's packed with a lot of
really cool subliminal messages a lot of
tropes
well I think George Miller is really one
of the probably through the top three
top five filmmakers that I think they
should show in film schools to
illustrate the principle of show don't
tell yeah because George Miller's whole
thing is that I want you to be it but
he's like I want this to essentially
work as a silent film you can mute the
dialog and we'll make an effort it won't
make a difference you can still tell
what's going on you don't have to speak
the language you don't have to like
everything is visually told which is
awesome because you don't see a lot of
that in movies despite movies being a
visual medium room I feel like even
though you have that you can show people
pictures people still have like they too
much exposition and get way down and
stuff like that George Miller does not
[ __ ] with that he's just like road
warrior Mel Gibson very famously has 16
lines in the whole movie and you don't
notice that yeah you don't notice that
he doesn't speak much yeah cuz it cuz he
acts so much with his eyes it's I and
the scene and the story is written it is
unfolding so well so rapidly you don't
realize there isn't a lot of talking
yeah and there's I mean the story is
very simple it's very straightforward
and like I said that's kind
one of the best things about it is that
you don't need a lot of expository
dialogue so much it is told through
these little visual details and through
people's body language and their
expression and you can kind of infer a
lot of things just by what you're
looking at yeah now when fury road came
out some friends of ours didn't like it
they didn't think it had a story but I
think there's a lot of generational
differences some of the younger people
grow up where they're totally immune to
imagery and I think they're in a theater
looking at their cell phone and you know
answering messages on facebook on their
phone and they're not even really
looking at the street so a story that's
being told visually I think you lose a
lot of people today maybe yeah maybe
because they're not really paying it
they're not there so a TV to show AGD
that they're not even watching the
images they're just trying to listen for
dialogue yeah and you know the story
like this you don't really need dialogue
yeah you said really don't you have to
watch what happens yeah and some of
these some of the younger Millennials I
don't think get that yeah let's all I'm
not gonna say all because the biggest I
mean there's some young guys are just
looking they just busted it not over
this to if you look at that yeah oh yeah
that's that's that's what I was gonna
say it's like if you go and watch like
some Millennial age reviewers they
[ __ ] love the road warrior and they
[ __ ] love fury road yeah well the
ones that reviewed it did yeah true yeah
so I think there's you know we know
people that watch this that didn't get
it yeah there but I mean that said the
coolest thing about the road warrior
obviously is the [ __ ] action the
stunts right they're just but the movie
is just [ __ ] bonkers
yeah these movies were made in a time
where dudes and actually get killed
making the movies yeah or get seriously
injured and when you get hit in the head
with a motorcycle you've got a fun
behind yeah I did yeah that was a Mad
Max one and then in met in Mad Max 2 a
guy comes off of a motorcycle and his
feet accidentally clipped the tarmac
dune buggy that was nice
tumbling through the air it broke both
his legs at remember I think we broke
one of his legs or possibly both his
legs he's tumbling through the air for
about 100 feet and just lands on the
ground and ending up you know I've been
through mini motorcycle wrecks you just
hit like a sack of [ __ ] oh god that's
why and I was watching some other like
clips and some other reviews of road
warrior like before we did this and I
found a clip of the actual stunt like
where this is in the movie they left it
in which you know of course you would
know because it looks [ __ ] epic yeah
but you know if you see the actual stunt
and him actually landing I was just like
oh [ __ ] I didn't even like watch it no
it was so nasty
yeah now in fury road they use safety
harnesses that they CG doubt yeah that
was a little safer the way they did it
yeah you know they got a little more
mature you know it's no longer the 70s
of the 80s yeah although still I'm still
amazing that nobody got killed on yeah
safety harness yeah because it looked
like in a lot of those stunts I don't
think safety but I'm in road warrior you
can actually tell if they're jumping off
the back of a motorcycle and climbing up
the side of it yeah 18-wheeler they're
raising yeah and they're running across
the top of truck yeah and they really
are wrecking cars and you see the guy in
behind the wheel going through a roll
whatever the cars just disintegrated and
he's in there and you know these are
stuntmen but a stuntman is just a dude
who's nuts enough to do it yeah yeah it
doesn't make you superhuman right ya
know and like I said I'm sure I mean
that one dude for sure got all busted
out yeah now the guy in the first Mad
Max the guy that got hit than the
motorcycle back in the head mean I'm
pretty busted up today actually I think
I think I remember him saying that he
just got up he didn't realize that it
happened look he said evidently it
looked worse on film than it did
and it really because it happened so
quickly yeah tyre hit him in the back of
the head kind of shovel shove his shove
his head down into his chest and this is
pretty neat a lot of good motorcycle
wrecks and all of them actually but oh
yeah next one had some good rap
motorcycle wrecks yeah but like I said I
mean road warrior and really until fury
road came out I kind of think road
warrior was like the quintessential I
don't think anyone had topped is
particularly the vehicular stunts in
that I don't think we're topped until
fury road camera which was awesome
because beyond thunderdome wasn't really
via as vehicle based I think more story
based yeah it's a good movie it's my
least favorite yeah my two of them but
it's worth watching yeah it is Mad Max
in the Mad Max world yeah yeah but one
of the things that I've noticed about
these movies it escapes a lot of people
is that these each one of these stories
except for maybe the first one each one
of these movies is a tale being told to
you by someone else and they're told to
almost into religious mythology yeah
like at the end of road warrior you find
out it's the feral kid who's told you
this whole story and he was the what is
it the leader of the five tribes right
yeah you know and then you find out in
Beyond Thunderdome that the whole thing
is being told to you by the girl who is
the Priestess of the airplane kids I
forgot you know what the demon it will
tribe was she's telling you the story so
how they you know that how Captain
Walker got them to the city where they
were living and then
fury road actually ends with a quote for
some kind of a futuristic personal
apocalyptic religious book yeah so
you're being told these tales as part of
a religious mythology yeah which is why
it was weird because when fury road came
out it seemed like some people were kind
of hung up about where is this in the
time line stuff like that it doesn't
matter
no really I'll stand alone we stand
alone there about this character he's
kind of like and I'm
obviously we're not the first people to
make this comparison but it's like he's
a Christ figure he's shown us being
crucified with little children going
along the back of his arms yeah
Beyond Thunderdome he's yeah I guess you
could say of an apocalyptic Christ
savior type figure right and he's also
like I said you can compare the Mad Max
movie still like you know samurai movies
or a particular types of westerns like
the man with no name and that kind of
stuff where he just like kind of blows
into town and he's like a reluctant hero
he doesn't really he's very insular he's
very self-centered and then he kind of
reluctantly gets pulled into these other
people's struggles and ends up doing the
right thing in the end but never stays
in any one place yeah there were some
complaints about fury road that Oh max
was not the hero in the movie he's not
even the main character he's not the
main character he's not really in
character in Mad Max 2 or you know in
Mad Max 2 the story where the movie were
talking about now the actual hero I
would say traditional hero is actually
the driver captain yeah all right he's
the one that ends up saving the tribe he
saves max yeah you know he's actually a
good guy
yeah on the back of his helicopter or
his gyrocopter he's got the image of a
nude woman you know and I mean which and
that that was you know it's kind of all
symbolic for him trying to recapture his
humanity yeah it's got like a
multicolored outfit you know with like a
fake carnation you know he's nice to the
ladies and he's actually does a lot of
the heroic stuff nacelles max but almost
in a different way well he's almost kind
of an antihero in a sir yeah Max is a
very morally gray character like I said
he usually does the right thing in the
end but in the beginning he only does
things for his own ends right I mean
look at the part where like in the road
warrior where him in the gyro captain
and they see the gang and they're
basically like raping a woman and like
you know killing the guy who like to
take the glass or whatever and he's just
kind of like man and the woman gets
killed and the jogger cams
and the jogger comes all bummed out
Mel's just like whatever I don't care
and you know and then like he'll go down
there and he goes to like help the guy
but he only helps the guy because he
wants and should go to the oil refinery
and get gas that's all he wants his guys
right so the charity cat was more about
trying to recapture humanity yeah and
actually try because he's a good person
he's a very straightforward good person
wants to be left alone he's running from
all this he doesn't care trying not
trying not to get in the end he kind of
breaks his own ethos his own rule rising
goes ok I'm healthy yeah and he usually
pays the price yeah you know like he in
this movie he loses his car and the
right and he gets busted up really badly
yeah in his legendary car it's a xB
Falcon which is a really cool Australian
take off on the Mustang you know I
didn't sell it in this country and sell
in this country hit they sold similar
cars made up of similar thing right but
not that exact one he but not that exact
car I mean that is probably one of the
most iconic movie cars
yeah those in the history there's a
couple of replicas out there that are
very close to that same look they're
showing some combinations of things that
can't happen like that supercharger
can't really go on that end that motor
if I remember correctly there was some
little details the supercharger that's
pictured going on that motor can't go on
that motor yeah they're you they're
using a dummy supercharger and a real in
some shots and a real supercharging in
other shops yeah some guys have tried to
recreate that car you run into some
problems but hey you know I'm not
totally well-versed on it you know
that's just off the top my head from
what I remember yeah but the car almost
becomes a character in itself right yeah
and it's like it's like a hallmark of
the series yeah and then I was telling
you this story
each one is movies this car tends to
appear and then it is destroyed but then
in the next movie you see this car again
and then this
yeah well I think that's good though
because I think that's almost like
George Miller recom n ting on loss
because look at all the stuff that and
this is kind of a classic this is why
that Mad Max I think is such a resonant
character around the world
really he's a very relatable character I
mean yeah he's like he's silent and you
know he doesn't talk a lot or he doesn't
like express his feelings and he seems
like he doesn't have feelings
but this is a man who has been hurt so
much that he has just decided to turn it
all off I'm good [ __ ] about anybody I
don't give a [ __ ] about anything I'm
just gonna live you know just basically
like an animal he's reduced to animal
instinct and in fury road they kind of
go into the PTSD element which I really
like they just really do that in any of
the earlier movies so I liked that they
added that element yeah where you can
actually see his suffering and see how
much all this stuff was still haunting
him I mean you kind of got a little bit
of that in the road warrior because he
looked like a very like you could infer
that you know because obviously if you
saw the first movie and actually at the
beginning a road warrior this show a
flashback that show clips from the first
movie nation and said you know they
showed his wife and baby getting killed
so you know that he's been through some
[ __ ] right the cool thing about fury
road is that like in a lot of his
flashbacks and stuff those are like
different people yes so you can almost
infer that that might not even have
Ben's original family like he might have
gotten other you know from hooked up
with other family was later on because
like I said the timeline is not it
doesn't matter because these are like
mythological tales told about this
person right who kind of swept in helped
us right then was gone right like a
thief in the night you know I mean so so
it doesn't really matter like oh is this
20 years this is five years it doesn't
matter yeah I don't get don't get hung
up on you
because it doesn't really matter some
mythological tales about a
post-apocalyptic warrior that came and
saved your tribe yeah then left and then
left right who's never seen and then was
never seen again right and like I said
that's very similar to you know some
place with westerns and ER samurai move
our samurai movie or something like that
just this this reluctant hero that comes
in and gets sucked into other people's
stories and like I said that was one
thing that really pissed me off like
that some people got pissed off about
fury roads no it's all about furiosa but
uh I'm like one Mad Max was in a
shit-ton again he was in it and almost
as much as Charlize Theron was but
that's how all of the movies are that's
his whole character right is that he
comes in and he doesn't want to help
like initially he gets into it for
selfish reasons yeah but then he kind of
ends up getting a little bit of heat and
it happens in the road warrior where he
kind of developed some feelings for the
feral kid because he remembers his own
kid and you know at first he's kind of
like go away kid or oh by the way I love
the feral kid I don't like I don't like
kids and movies generally but that kid
is [ __ ] awesome yeah I love like he's
bugging this big like pumpkin smile
[Music]
understand what they're seeing you know
max didn't want to get involved with
other people because from his point of
view they were gonna die you know yeah
he will miss them yeah and you don't
want to get involved with the person
that's a guard right and you know he he
came in and he told him one time he told
the the tribe that was refining the fuel
that said all you guys this is hopeless
you know you shouldn't have hope yeah
well you guys are wasting your time
yeah yes which is also that that um
comes up again in fury road to where he
actually says outright hope is a mistake
yeah but then he ends up giving them
hope right in the end like even almost
without meaning to
yeah I would probably rate the movies
like this you want to see Mad Max 2
first if you've never seen any of these
movies see Mad Max 2 first then see fury
road yeah right now Mad Max 1 and Mad
Max 3 Beyond Thunderdome I think of good
supplements to the story yeah but you
know but Mad Max 1 you don't actually
have to see that movie not really no I
mean like I said you can infer a lot
just from watching road warrior
it's kind of just distilled down to the
essence yeah and really do you need to
know a lot about his character
I think it's better that he kind of
remains mysterious which is why I like
the character so much because he doesn't
talk very much but you can tell that
he's like I said that he's been through
a lot of [ __ ]
although Mad Max one does have an
awesome scene that I couldn't understand
what I was seeing for a long time until
until I saw a documentary explaining
what it was I was seeing when the
Nightrider breaks out of prison or it
gets you know busted out of prison by
his girlfriend and he's running from the
cops he tries to go around a wrecked
vehicle and he hits a button which
ignites a rocket that was right into the
into the trunk of his car they actually
did this for this movie they had no idea
of work they bought a military surplus
booster rocket that you used to like
launch launched something off of an
aircraft carrier yeah if it's overloaded
they stuffed that into the back of that
car and launched it and you see it so
badly Oh course you know you see the
paper trail and the heat blasted out of
the back of that thing out in broad
daylight car bear just you can see the
car just complex underneath it is
clearly a crazy person but in the best
possible way
you could probably take Mad Max in like
take the first first 15 or 20 minutes of
bad max one and then cut and then take
like the last 15 minutes of Mad Max 1
and cut out all the stuff in the middle
and then splice the the ending in the
beginning together and it's an
action-packed movie yeah but the middle
of Mad Max 1 is kind of slow yeah yeah
cuz like I said I mean I really like the
first movie but it's not it's not like
the other ones
it's
an action that's not action there's like
a lot of action in it but it's not like
a straight-up action movie you could
tell it they didn't have the money yeah
you could tell so it's kind of like and
like you said it's probably good you
watch road warrior watch fury road
that's kind of all you need to know
about the character now Miller I don't
know you know if Miller's straight or
not but I've noticed that if he's
straight or gay or whatever but I've
noticed that every Mad Max movie has a
leather daddy at least one leather daddy
and yeah Mad Max is boss cheaper boots
namely feet feet and he was a good cop
bald cop or the mustache wearing all
leather Burnett walkin around shirtless
with it and there's some leather daddy
issues going on there oh yeah and
obviously was in the in his second twins
and they were keep on his slave boy and
his slave boy the golden youth like
think it's what they get what they call
yeah I don't know humungous is 11 well
he just has like the S&M yeah yes down
here but see I don't know if that's just
because because I feel like in the 80s a
lot of bad guys in movies looked like
that because that was something I mean
now it's like everyone knows what S&M
gear looks like everything is but back
then it was very taboo underground and
so I think since they were trying to
make them other and they were trying to
villains they're like what's the best
way to do that yeah you can make them
look really disturbing and scary by
putting like Mohawks on them right
because they did that a lot in the
eighties like all the bad guys look like
punks yeah you know what's even though
punk rockers in those days are like 110
pounds that's what I mean even though it
look you know I came from that yeah
that's kind of scene so I'm hung out
with a lot of pumps back in the day I'm
like they were like the nicest people
everything like all the goth people and
all the punk people and death rock
people it's like those are like the
nicest people ever they were never never
be villains why not be villains yeah
because it was a it was a safe way of
getting a villain into the movie without
you know I mean getting into PC issues I
guess that's the white kids aren't gonna
give a problem yeah they're not a file
lawsuit you know what the funny thing
and I discovered
today and I didn't notice for the guy
that played was in road warrior was he
was unlikely shits on another movie he
was in [ __ ] commando yeah he was also
in the weird science well yet playing
essentially that's what yeah that's kind
of what I it's funny because I think I
saw weird science before I saw road
warrior you didn't get the reference
well I did like I knew it was from Road
Warrior but I hadn't seen the movie so I
was just kinda like he was the only
actual person I'm looking more and more
and Joe might have been a leather daddy
too because in some of the cartoon or
not cartoon they had little comic books
that would just like a prequel extended
universe endowment books made by a man
either kind of inferred that you know he
would dress those girls that he was
trying to impregnate dress him up like
war boys that he was born to the boys
that he was the girls it did kind of see
what yeah he only had the women around
for breeding stock basically I don't
yeah if it burns yeah and you know you
don't realize that those girls
volunteered for that yeah they weren't
captured or anything well nobody was
trying to get into the city Elsa said
she was kidnapped yeah but that was a
different story I think because people
were trying to get into the Citadel
right for safety I don't think that that
I don't think that's a different movie
yeah but I don't think that those girls
were captured per se but I don't think
they were free to leave well no of
course they weren't they were it kept
them locked in a vault well the the
extended universe comic books said that
there was kind of a contractual
agreement it involved with this is that
that they were taken in and they had
four attempts three or four attempts to
get pregnant and if they failed that
they were kicked out yeah well like I
said that I'm not sure if that's what
end up having to furiosa because she
straight up says yeah he was can that
she was kidnapped I'm just kidding and I
don't they don't say this in the movie
but I inferred that she had maybe been
one of the breeding some beginning and
that maybe she didn't get pregnant or
she couldn't get pressed so they go so
they got rid of her but then she was
kind of bad
good at other things so they let her be
better story and we don't I don't know
whether or not her she lost that arm or
she was born without that arm yeah yeah
I'm not really sure about that a little
bit but see that's the cool thing and
that's the cool thing about Road Warrior
and that's the cool thing about fury
road is that so much of the story like
somebody's little details and stuff it
just implies a much larger universe yeah
but they don't really explain it like
having furiosa looser arm we don't know
yeah but it's an intriguing thing to
think about
yeah but these are excellent movies
there's a lot more to them than people
give them credit for
you've made that best especially Mad Max
2 and fury road they'll seem like a lot
to the movies and if you don't never
watch them this is a this is an entire
series that you guys should take a look
at yeah I mean like I said Road Warrior
up until fury road came out probably one
of the better well the time probably one
of the best action movies in the 80s oh
yeah easy yeah I would say up there with
die hard yeah even though they're very
different yeah it's not they're very
different movements there in terms of
intensity in action yes Jana and stuff
like that it's pretty much non-stop
[ __ ] action yeah non-stop badassery
yeah and like I said until fury road
came out which was just like [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] we saw that we saw fury road
in the theater was six times so yeah
something like when first time we saw
three IMAX 3d and it's like we got beat
up I know I left the fear going someone
just kicked our axis yeah it just pulls
you like the whole time is just
pummeling you the whole that's great is
that Miller is like oh you thought Mad
Max 2 is cool all right yeah [ __ ] yeah
check this out yeah my whole my whole
like visual of this movie was like
George Miller just like an old band now
yeah he was like this is 70s [ __ ] how
to make movies yeah I pictured him just
like there's like a [ __ ] huge like
mushroom cloud behind it he's just like
walking away like chewing gum
like there's supposed to be metal there
supposed to be more movies coming that
he has he has it he's handed reins over
to a guy that who understands the genre
and who he trusts I mean I think these
movies done I know an alien this guy
who's doing it basically kind of did
fury road okay he did like if it would
be hard to top furious I mean seriously
they're easily easily one of the best
movies not even action movie the best
movies that I've seen passed down in ten
years twenty years
fury road actually restored my hope in
the movies yeah you can go to a movie
and see a badass [ __ ] movie other
reviewers say the exact thing the same
thing that it's like this restored their
faith in the medium because you go to
see it and you're like I never thought
that I would see a movie that I mean I
could [ __ ] cry and how [ __ ] good
that is it's [ __ ] epic it doesn't
speak to everybody member we took that
one couple with us it is yeah yeah some
people in here for it but seriously I
mean we've seen we saw it six times in
the theater
we bought it on blu-ray and we present
and actually when we re watch the red
warrior for this I was like now
[Music]
fury road restored some hope Blade
Runner the new Blade Runner movie kind
of restored some hope that that movie
looks really good I know you like that
movies movie of the year we need to go
see that before it's out of the theaters
it still in theatres I think so we need
to go see it before it goes out of the
theater yeah that's my favorite movie
that we've seen here so far and you know
some people some people say that you
know force awakens wasn't any good I
liked force away I really liked it I
expected it to suck yeah like I went
into it thinking it was gonna stop
because you know wrinkles you know how
that goes but you know but I was like
yay didn't suck it was awesome robot
this was good too I really liked
give me that Star Wars fix yeah the
trailers on this new what's it called
last Jedi yeah
that looks good too yeah
we're yeah we're probably we should do
the I mean we I know we don't really do
new movies unless we're talking about
like I said we just did fury road which
came in a couple years ago but only in
relation to the road warrior and really
they're kind of - road warrior and fury
road are kind of two sides of the same
coin is very similar that's a story yeah
like it's a similar structure it's
almost kind of like road warriors like
the gritty yeah it's real gritty low
budget II kind of fury road has a nice
color palette to it you know then yeah
incorporated more elements in it and the
cars are a lot better like I wouldn't
call like I wouldn't call the road
warrior a work of art
fury road I would not hesitate yeah
every frame of that movie is beautiful
yeah and even yeah it's like an opera
even the CG which they had to put some
CG yeah there's not much that ya had to
get rid of the damn tire tracks yeah I
think they had them makes a car get
sucked up by a tornado tornado like a
fan so the man even that was good yeah
and some of the stuff that people
thought was CG out of the fury road
isn't like all the stuff flying off that
car you know that comes toward your face
on throat your face that was that's
actually live-action they did wreck that
they read that thing that stuff a ring
in a way that car flew it was this
funny-looking it did look like like it
was fake it wasn't that good cuz we
watched the behind the scenes yeah we
have it that stunt happened pretty much
the way you see it maybe they enhance
the color and stuff like that which they
do on every movie right but you can see
in the [ __ ] behind the scenes [ __ ]
they flipped that [ __ ] truck yeah and
that guy is playing a guitar and then on
the front of that car on that stage and
that is real fire and that is real fire
coming up
think some people thought that would CG
final coming out no it's real it's a
slam doing it's [ __ ] flavor free
movie [ __ ] and you didn't have any eyes
[Laughter]
like I said I kind of get sucked into
like I'd sort of watch other people
hasn't mentioned the reason why we're
doing this reviews cuz i got i got Mad
Max 2 or Road war and got it on blu-ray
yeah the blu-ray transfer looks
excellent it looks a lot better than it
did on DVD from 1981 they must have
cleaned the [ __ ] out of this looks good
because it looks so crisp and it looks
really like all the colors in there and
the landscapes and everything like that
never saw the same never saw this movie
in the theater no I don't know
and I mostly saw it either on VHS or
cake or cake me yeah on those old
cathode ray tube televisions yeah I
think I saw it maybe on DVD or a regular
television right if you look at on HDTV
yeah and the soundtrack sounds a lot
better yeah well that's like a big part
of it and you know that with fury row to
like a lot of the sounds yeah
soundtrack because they tell a lot of
the story through the sound too and like
I said again this is really the way to
tell a story without talking yeah oh and
also I have Mad Max one on blu-ray if it
transferred out really good too yeah
actually really they're worth they're
worth getting yeah I'm blu-ray we don't
have beyond not yet I'll get it yeah
because like yeah because we would like
to exploit that that's the least people
like that seem to like that movie the
least I think no maybe not I think
people don't actually don't like Mad Max
the one they're all very different
movies I think yeah Beyond Thunderdome I
don't know I
as a very Hollywood feel - yeah that's
what I didn't like about it's like a
mainstream movie yeah it's structured
like a mainstream movie there's a lot
more dialogue it's a lot more the
stories a lot more complex Tina Turner
actually did a good job
I like Tina Turner in it but you could
tell that's like will they wanted to put
her in and they could put some more
songs in it cuz she was super famous at
the day and you know [ __ ] like that so I
didn't really like that it's LA oh we're
gonna do like all this tie-in was like
others library I didn't really like that
like I liked there were a lot of kids in
it yasya which is that's usually not a
good thing yeah this like putting the
candy in there I don't know what a candy
is like from the Gamera movie yeah Kenny
is always a little cute little boy in
shorts that calls camera and knows every
day's everything knows he can he can
answer things that are just you know
that an adult would never know like oh
yes well Gamera he came from the from
the solar system on the outside of the
how do you know this I know you know
there in the command center you know
yeah we're good Japanese Defense Force
and they still I got a [ __ ] door and
this little five-year-old with shorts is
telling them how to fix this and they're
lifting hair listening to the look it's
like shut up the adults are talking but
yeah that's that Kenny is and I think
that they got the same person to dub
every single gamma movie bro they all
have that [ __ ] annoying voice it's
probably a woman like trying to do a
little boys and a lot of times I get
real skeptical when I see a little kid
in an action movie on whether the man
here comes akin no feral kid the feral
Cuba is the opposite of like I know some
people think he's annoying and [ __ ] like
that like I have seen some movies just
thought the feral kid was annoying but I
[ __ ] love it now you see my blu-rays
[ __ ] fine because he's like a little
animal is that like his [ __ ]
boomerang [ __ ] and like I said it's
the yeah the scene where max gives him
the little the little crank thing from
boxing
like and he gets this like huge smile on
his face and it's like so genuine and so
funny it's like I just [ __ ] love that
moment that character and I have to
mention to how much I love the [ __ ]
gyro captain and the yeah the actor that
played him which name is Bruce Spence I
think is the name he stole that show he
made who really did like he said he's
kind of a hero exactly he's actually the
hero of the story yeah pretty much
and he was in some other [ __ ] - I think
he was in one of the Matrix movies he
was in Revenge of the Sith I think
although he was under so much makeup
that you really tell but he's so skinny
in this movie because evidently he'd
just got out of the hospital I don't
know what he received hence I'm gonna be
on this video exhaustive fantastic
character when you when you first
introduced to him he jumps up out of a
hole in the ground yeah I do love this
with the Australian even though
sometimes I have no idea what the
[ __ ] thing but I can understand yeah
well yeah most of the time but like like
I said the see with the feral kid
anything with the dryer captain and the
scene with Mel Gibson eating the dog
food yeah I love that but like the dinky
B or whatever it but any of our
Australian what's really neat is they
still make that many gives it to the dog
and the tire comes like Hannity like
it's just such it it's such a great
moment because it shows you like how
much what people have devolved yeah
traffic's great [ __ ] dog yeah and wet
wes is basically just an overgrown
baboon jumping around with his ass
all chapters all chapter has this
he's jumping around like a baboon
looking for [ __ ]
yeah well it's funny because like some
of it some of the other review said that
exact same thing it's like the the
reason that he has the chaps on with his
ass hanging out it's not so much for
sexual reasons but because he's like a
monkey yeah he's like it was like he's
like it what he's like devolved well
he's got like things like the main yeah
I think yeah I think a lot of the jump
in yeah a lot of the S&M [ __ ] for me
like the yeah and he had like the the
red mohawk like a wordpress thing
they're trying to make them look
animalistic yeah and then showing
flashing like just having a little bit
of Empire and whether one man threatened
another man with rape right you know I
mean it's kind of like damn some kind of
Spartan homosexuality where you know
they're raping the defeated soldiers oh
yeah although they read some of the
women took a regular women's if they
kill them that was weird
yeah women but they keep the boys but
yeah like I said that that's how they
were kind of trying to establish the the
bad guys being more actually sick and
the people in the oil refinery were kind
of more civilized I guess they had white
clothes and actually one covered up and
I just I just remember something though
humongous is troops though there were
women in their way there were women in
there yeah yeah well that's what I mean
and some people have said oh maybe he
was um you know he was a like in jail
and the olden any that was like his
prison business oh and also I should
mention too and I think other reviewers
have mentioned this but originally Lord
humungus
was supposed to be the goose goose yeah
which they should have done that I don't
know like well you should have been like
the goose fell to the dark side every
guy what the original concept was
because yeah he got all burned up at the
beginning there's gonna be a scene there
where the goose recognizes Max and tries
to get him to join his side that time
stuff and that would have been awesome
but I think they I think they decided
not to do that because I think Miller
figured that a lot of the audience
hadn't seen the goose was what they
would think they wouldn't understand the
significance if he should have done it
anyway cuz that could have sold more mad
at Max one videos yeah VHS tapes what
was that movie about go back and see it
they've been awesome I thought yeah I
was yeah when I like saw that bit of
trivia
I was kinda I can't decide like whether
I liked that better or whether
Lord humungus is better it's just like a
San Juan character I can't decide I
think it'd have been I mean obviously if
it had been goose that would have been
like really that would have added like a
lot of emotional weight to the story
because here's like his buddy like from
the first movie he got all [ __ ] up and
burned up and everything like that and
they turned it yeah like it's really
Star Wars each other thing that might
have been kind you know his Lord
humungus is monologues to try to get
people to surrender to it work we're
kind of thoughtful you know we have too
much pain we have all lost and all that
kind of stuff remember that was kind of
the cool thing about like he looked like
this big hulking villain with this
[ __ ] metal mask on all let's get and
he's all burned and [ __ ] up and
everything like that but then like when
he talks this is very like well-spoken
right I like that juxtaposition yeah
like he wasn't just a brute yeah and
then the guys the the the guys in the in
the old army uniform with the samurai
sword realize that this is among sounds
like a reasonable man yeah yeah
I think though you just walk away yeah
so let's walk away I think I think
they're here I will call out my dogs of
war I think that they I think they would
have killed him anyway
if they walked out of there well that's
time of his life I think that was the
implication there like yeah just walk on
out of there and then they'll just kill
them all it'd take you because you I
mean if you are coming from a more
Rother mindset like that you can't leave
those people alive cuz they'll try and
sneak back inside we're gonna take it I
mean as valuable as gas is in this
universe you know you wouldn't just like
[ __ ] take off because some dudes on a
motorcycle clothes you do right it's
like yeah yeah we're totally going and
then you'll go hide and then yo Matt
yeah then you'll call up your troops and
you'll go and like [ __ ] run them out
of there now one thing that one
criticism of this and I want to just to
get your thoughts on this real quick
before we end it do you think it's dumb
that that when max leaves the oil
refineries car he basically drives right
into the bad guys area it was it because
he's being stupid or because he's being
cocky no I think I think the way it was
shot I think it you're inferring that
that's what happened because I looked up
like I think what had happened was I
think the entire camp had been
surrounded so there was no way out yeah
cuz I have heard other people like who's
why did he drop leg right through the
[ __ ] camp and then like they [ __ ]
wrecked his car and they killed his dog
they don't spawn I think Mad Max who
also had some you know budgetary
limitations yeah I think
humongous his army was I think they
wanted it to be bigger than what it what
it really was yeah they didn't have
enough money in here when you see it
it's probably only about 50 guys yeah
and maybe about 20 vehicles all right
but I think it was supposed to be more
like they were selling a couple hundred
guy yeah and a hundred vehicles and so
there was no way he could have resolved
no way he could
I think that's problems so it was just
because of budget is because of buzz
because like I said when he had you know
when George Miller was given two hundred
million dollars to make fury road yeah
you know there was a huge art there was
a huge army and also the way they shot
it like the nice thing about fury road
too is that you can tell where [ __ ] is
in relation to each other because he
does like a lot of really long like
tracking shots and like these big
landscape kind of shots so you can tell
where the gas farm is you can tell where
the bullet farm is you are gas town
sorry you know you can tell where
everything is you can tell where
everyone is in relation to each other
and [ __ ] like that and I think that if
you watch Road Warrior you can see kind
of the the kernel of what would come out
in fury road is like he is really really
good at directing and editing action and
choreographing it so one so it has
emotional weight it means something also
you can tell where everyone is in
relation to each other you can tell
what's going on even when he closes up
and does like tight shots and stuff like
that you have to tell where everyone is
another thing about fury road is that
the music is [ __ ] badass I know
everything makes everything extremely
intense and the quarry have the fight
choreography it is a lot more
complicated than it appears to be upon
first viewing in other words you'll see
one thing happening in in the foreground
and in the background something else is
happening
yeah doesn't really come into play until
a couple cuts later in other words like
in the background you see the troops on
their vehicles staging the next phase of
the attack it's very well done if
somebody accidentally drops a bomb in
the background you see the bomb get run
over by another car and get it then blow
up in the background they didn't even
focus on that yeah you know what
that's what I mean it's like what we saw
fairies in and the more you see it like
more you see and the more if you pick
this [ __ ] up I'm like how the [ __ ] did
they even make how did they make that
how do they do it what they do if
there's much [ __ ] going on here and how
they keep traffic area rode with one big
story board
yeah they drew it like a cartoon yeah
and and they shot the movie to match
that story boy yeah Network good it
really did I mean there's so there
wasn't even any dialogue in the
storyboard they said I'll worry about
that later
they added this day analog I mean
there's probably more dialogue in fury
road than there is in Rogue Warrior not
much though and especially Mad Max he
doesn't really have that many lines
there might be more dialogue in Mad Max
too
you think yeah there's no Papagayo and
all the guys inside the inside the
refinery they have whole kind of yeah
there aren't any real conversations
except maybe when they get furiosa to
the green place which is talking with
the other with the other women in the
tribes and I think there's conversations
there but they're not they're stripped
down there very yes they are very like
just a few weren't us yeah maybe I'd be
curious to see if anybody yeah yeah is
it a comparison because to me it seemed
like there was more dialogue inferior
above maybe not I don't think so yeah
maybe not maybe right well you know it's
having that's right it's time for me to
just walk away
I just just walk away very nice all
right well I hope you guys have enjoyed
this actually kind of super-sized
we kind of went off yeah we went off on
walk away talking about keys get excited
when we talk about fury road because I
[ __ ] love that movie so much but okay
so not actually be a road warrior review
it might be a Mad Max review of all them
yeah that's what I mean we mostly focus
on yeah that's just what we'll call it
I'll just I'll put the other movie
titles in the key words we might revisit
it
we probably yeah we probably will we
will definitely be coming back to the
Mad Max universe yeah I think through I
think you have to talk about fury road
yeah I would like I would like to do a
whole hour just gushing about that movie
because it's [ __ ] epic and everyone
should see it and if you don't like it
you saw it's fine if it's fine if you
don't like it you're just wrong but
anyway so I hope you guys have enjoyed
this movie review go check out our
regular show go check out our patreon
and all that other stuff that I usually
say and our new episode will be out on
Tuesday as usual yeah and just wait yeah
there you go